it's never been easier to be a homeless
person and democrat-run cities why
bother getting a job and cleaning
yourself up when you can enjoy free
meals and get high all day thanks to
Liberal policies Portland alone has over
700 encampments and one woman there is
actually bragging about the perks of
living on the streets how is it like
being homeless in Portland
it's a
it's up we got so many out here because
they feed you three meals a day you
don't have to do but stay in your tent
or party or if you'd smoke a lot of dope
you can do that it's like you wake up
you go eat a Blanche get high go eat a
blente for lunch get high go eat dinner
get high and that's all you do all day
long every day doesn't feel like that's
really helping anybody it's not that's
why you see all the tents I spoke with
the homelessness Outreach volunteer who
shot that video and he says it's time
for some tough love
sure someone who's in the middle of
their addiction is going to continue to
say yes to you if you just keep handing
them stuff right but what if you stop
handing them stuff and says look I
expect you to meet me halfway now you
know change is difficult but what I've
found is by giving a homeless person
responsibility they take that
responsibility so you're saying
beautiful
you usually don't hear that Greg from
Liberal politicians well it's well first
I want to start with the the preface
that we all have to do which is we're
not talking about people on the street
who are there not by choice right but
however we are starting to see that that
is not even close to the majority of
homeless right now it is the transient
lifestyle has now become glamping it's
like you can go you can get a tent you
can live there and this is what happens
and I think what's happening is even the
Outreach the volunteers the people that
work or the homeless are saying man this
is this is just a scheme this is now
people are just doing it because they
can live above and beyond civil society
which I get you know I understand what
she's talking about no boss no bills no
mortgage mortgages free meds free meals
but there's got to be some reciprocity
to society don't make our lives hell you
can have your commune in the desert hell
I'll help pay for that but you can't be
on the street defecating you can't can't
you know scare the crap out of our kids
right you can't make our lives a living
hell we get it we understand that there
is that you don't want to live by our
rules but then you don't get to live
with us right it's like that it's like
the parents
cutting off the drug addict and kicking
them out of the house no matter how much
they love them cities have to do this
they're homeless by choice they are not
your children they are not your
responsibility we are paying for that
responsibility and it's their lifestyle
we are supporting a lifestyle it's time
to stop I will pay to create that
lifestyle as an experiment somewhere in
the desert tense Galore drugs Galore
hell I'll visit I'll be the mayor what
do they call that big party in the
desert wherever but burning man yeah
this would be smelly man yeah so Greg
says you know we're all paying for this
the taxpayers in Portland are paying for
free tents they're paying for free
needles they're praying for free food
why stop why get off the streets well
and also there was just an election and
the voters there can decided to continue
with the leadership that they had so
part of it for me is like well okay then
that's this is what you have decided to
do local decision making and you get to
decide and that's the case now I do not
think it's compassionate to allow people
to live like that and I think that the
guest you had is right that tough love
is compassionate that's what you know
for everybody and the these drugs some
of them they make you not care about
your personal condition so you're happy
to be an intent and you could be in a
city like Denver where they don't
enforce the no tent policy and now
you've got tents everywhere or look at
Washington DC you leave you leave Union
Station and there's a tents everywhere
that should be that should be
unacceptable and our police officers one
that should not be social workers they
shouldn't have to be but they also
should be given the power that they need
to move these people on into care if
they need it and the last thing I would
say is it's also not compassionate to
the families who are worried about their
loved ones who are out there living on
the street and are able to do so without
having to come home you know I have to
tell you I I have been very critical of
Mayor Eric Adams but he did one good
thing and I want to give him credit for
it Eric Adams is he's trying to get the
homeless into hospitals mental health
facilities and there's a lot of pushback
from you know from the left from people
who say oh it's not fair they say
specifically uh that it is inhumane to
force them to go into a mental hospital
but he's got it under the umbrella of if
they can't take care of themselves it
might be a danger to themselves or
others then the police have the right to
take them into a mental health facility
where immediately they get a psychiatric
evaluation and they could stay there not
unlike what I did as a judge now one of
the other things that and this is our
fault it is our fault in Missouri it is
against the law to sleep on the street
in New York now Eric Adams is saying if
you appear to have a mental illness
we're going to pull you off the street
involuntarily and put you in a mental
health facility and the problem is
people in Oregon they get free food they
get a LAX drug policy where they allow
the them to have an LST meth heroin and
everything else and cocaine and they
they take it as a like a violation like
getting a traffic ticket and they
suffered more fatalities in terms of
overdoses than they had ever so the
bottom line is this as a society we have
to make a decision are we going to
tolerate it or not are we going to
tolerate it or not
somewhere in the middle the 50 that your
guest said I think makes sense saying to
you've got to give us some and we're
going to continue to give you some it's
not saying tomorrow you can't come back
here right but there have to be
you know standards there have to be
goals that you need in order to keep
getting benefits that's how it works in
the welfare system and I think on the
Eric Adams front that that policy when I
first saw it I thought oh this is a good
thing because it feels dangerous there
especially in the Subways and things
like that and I think if you marry up
using police officers with social
workers to have those conversations with
people who are mentally ill because
that's really the problem that we have
mentally ill people on the street then I
think that we could probably do a lot of
good with that and people could get the
care that they need but one of the main
problems is we don't have enough shelter
beds for people anymore so when
Bloomberg was mayor of New York we had a
bed for every single homeless person in
the city if they wanted it and there
were tons of vans that would drive
around you've probably seen them picking
people up if they wanted a ride
especially on cold nights but just in
general and we don't have that anymore
under de Blasio it surpassed the number
of beds that we have and now it's
astronomical especially considering
what's going on with migration mental
illness we're not going to build enough
beds to get ourselves out of this
problem no but you have to have
somewhere that people can go that is
that's safe oh it's not a tent I want to
Brian kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now